dónde está el punto en la recta numérica
bueno aquí está aquí lo podemos ver pero
a lo que se refiere con esta pregunta es
qué número representa este punto verde
en la recta numérica sabemos que está
situado entre 3 y 4 es mayor que 3 sin
embargo es menor que 4 pero para saber
que tanto más grande es que 3
necesitamos saber qué distancia
representan estos espacios entonces
entre 3 y 4 tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
espacios iguales entonces cada una de
estas distancias mide lo mismo cada una
es un décimo una décima parte de la
distancia que hay entre 3 y 4 es decir
es uno de los 10 espacios iguales por lo
tanto si eso es una décima
y este otro espacio también mide una
décima y después avanzamos otro espacio
que también mide una décima y así ya
llegamos al punto verde observamos que
avanzamos de tres
+ 12
tres décimas entonces tenemos tres
y tres décimas si lo escribimos como
decimal entonces tendríamos el lugar de
las unidades
después de las unidades tenemos un punto
decimal después del decimal está el
lugar de las décimas entonces en el
lugar de las unidades tenemos tres
unidades
punto decimal y ahora cuantas décimas
vimos aquí vimos tres décimas
y podemos usar ambas notaciones podemos
usar 3 y 3 sobre 10 eso es 3 y 3 décimas
o 3.3
eso también es tres y tres décimas así
que el punto verde es 3.3 en la recta
numérica